the secret to believing in yourself step
number one figure out what you currently
say to yourself you need to pay
attention to what goes on in your head
throughout the day and look for the most
common negative thoughts step number two
figure out what new thoughts you want to
adopt look at your list of negative
thoughts and figure out the opposite of
those statements for example I am weak
becomes I am strong step number three
find proof for your new thoughts let's
say for example you've never worked out
before in this case simply doing a 30
minute workout routine is proof that you
are stronger step number four repeat
your new thoughts every time you find
proof so using the example from before
after doing your workout routine think
to yourself I am mentally strong step
number five repeat steps three and four
until your new thoughts become your
normal thoughts basically just keep
Gathering proof and keep repeating your
new thoughts to yourself nothing fancy
just rinse and repeat